[Music]
Bruce Bauer I write about the a droll
sciences for science news so I cover
everything from psychology to archeology
anthropology it's about food beings and
how we think and behave and that's
pretty much what it is psychologists are
currently going through a period of much
angst and worry over whether their
science can really be found to repeat
their findings whether it's a valid are
they truly on to something there's much
discussion now about how psychology
should pursue this issue and how can it
be solved this is something that we are
going to cover quite a bit in science
because it applies not just psychology
but the many areas of science right now
for scientists reproducibility is very
important because what it means is that
when they get one particular finding
it's important to know that people can
find it the same thing in it and it
allows with independent researchers
trying to see if in finding holes oh so
one aspect of the way psychologists
currently do business with significance
testing is to focus purely on the
average scores of groups and to compare
the averages of one group to another and
on average is considered to be
statistically significant or different
enough from the other group that they
consider that to be an effective but
averages can hide just as much as they
reveal and we've recently reported in
science news it can be very instructive
to look
averages but at individual differences
so when researchers recently looked at
individual differences between young
children learning what they call theory
of mind or how to understand and make
inferences about what others are
thinking or feeling the children show
very different rates of learning even
over a couple of years from age three
five and I think right now given a lot
of the controversy and anxiety over
significance testing and lack of
reproducibility there may be more of a
focus on individual difference and which
would be a very healthy move for the
field
[Music]